[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing the life of none other than
nicholas flamel
in my last video we looked at the story
of merlin an enigmatic figure that
appears to have made his way
into endless adaptations of folklore and
pseudohistorical accounts
the way that his story is told in some
instances makes it seem as though merlin
really walked the earth in exactly the
way that he has been described to us
however by analyzing the texts we can
deduce that merlin was created
by geoffrey of monmouth combining two
real and prominent
historical figures miradin wilt a north
patharnic prophet
and ambrosius relianus a romano british
war leader
so merlin was real in a way but the
thing that makes nicholas famel even
more of an enigma than merlin
is the fact that he completely and
totally existed
and his name and identity didn't really
change along the way
like merlin flamel is included in all
sorts of folklore
pseudo-historical accounts and even
historical accounts
he's all over the place and it makes him
that much more intriguing his character
and identity
the man he really was was clearly
interesting enough for people to adapt
into folklore
and that's exactly the way flamel found
his way into harry potter
let's start by taking a look at the real
nicholas female the man that all of
these fictional adaptations were based
on
flamel was a french scribe born in the
year 1330
in the city of pontois he lived in paris
for the majority of his life
and spent much time there over the
course of the 14th and 15th century
flamel was such an influential figure in
parisian history
that there is even a road named after
him called glue
nicola flamel even more interesting than
that one of flamel's original houses
still exists in paris to this day at 51
de montmorency it's been expressed that
fomel's
former home is the oldest stone house in
the city and there is even an
inscription on the wall which states
we plowmen and women living at the porch
of this house
built in 1407 are requested to say every
day
an our father and an ava maria praying
god that his grace forgive
poor and dead sinners on a day-to-day
basis flamel worked as a scribe and
manuscript seller
and ran two shops offering these
services in paris
flamel achieved a great deal of success
in his career and as a result it became
quite wealthy
in the year 1368 flamel would go on to
marry his wife
bergenel a generous benefactorist who
had a great deal of money from her
former two marriages
like flamel a road was named in her
honor after his demise
the pair were a couple of wealthy
philanthropists who lived good
solid lives bergenel passed away before
nicholas
in the year 1397 and nicholas lived
until the year 1418
which was a considerable amount of time
for someone to live in that era
but posthumously is when things really
start to get interesting for the
enigmatic figure that is nicholas flamel
sometime in the 17th century hundreds of
years after his death
legends started to appear about flamel
claiming that he was successful
alchemist
who a discovered the philosopher's stone
and b
achieved immortality the texts claim
that flamel had learned his alchemical
secrets
from a jewish converso on the road to
santiago de compostela
and that was really what sparked the
identity of flamel in fictional works
from that point onward flamel was no
longer just a wealthy scribe who lived a
reasonably long life
suddenly he was a master alchemist who
achieved immortality
it's crazy what can happen hundreds of
years after your death
flamel's legendary accomplishments as an
alchemist were first mentioned in
leave the figure hydroglyphic an
alchemical text first published in 1612.
the text outlined that flamel had
succeeded with two great achievements in
alchemy
the first being that he created the
philosopher's stone which was purported
to have turned base metals into gold
the second achievement was that he and
his wife had succeeded in creating
an elixir of life which allowed them to
achieve immortality
flamel was truly an icon in alchemy and
had reached legendary status within the
circles of alchemy by the mid-17th
century
he was even mentioned in sir isaac
newton's journals
so that pretty much covers both the real
flamel as well as the fictionally
adapted flamel
but what about the flamel of harry
potter where does he fit into all of
this
in harry potter law flamel actually
wasn't all too different than the flamel
of the 17th century texts and it's clear
that he had an influence on rowling
as the first film is named after the
very object which he is purported to
have created
in an interview rolling discusses flamel
nicholas flamel is a historical
character
flamel lived in france in the 14th
century and is supposed to have
discovered how to make a philosopher's
stone
there are mentions of sightings of him
through the centuries because he was
supposed to have gained immortality
there are still streets named after
flamel and his wife bernal
in paris the flamel of the harry potter
universe was born in the year 1326
i'm not sure why this is four years
earlier than the real flamel
but there you go there is a stark
difference in his lifespan
however as the original flamel died in
the year 1418
and the flamel of harry potter lived
until sometime between 1992
and 1996 not a bad go he ended up being
one of the oldest wizards in history
losing out only to wizard barry winkle
who lived to the age of 755.
the nicholas flamel of the harry potter
universe like every other witch and
wizard
of course also attended a wizarding
school in the early 14th century
flamel began attending bobaton academy
of magic
a french wizarding school located in the
pyrenees mountains of france
this is apparently also where he met his
wife
who stayed by his side for their
considerably long existence
nicholas kept a relatively low profile
for a lot of his life
remaining in his parisian home and
pursuing all sorts of alchemical
endeavors
in the 1890s flamel first met albus
dumbledore
who at the time was a brilliant teenager
that showed immense magical promise
as mentioned on dumbledore's chocolate
frog card dumbledore also achieved a
great deal of success in alchemy during
his lifetime
and i have no doubt that this was a
result of joint ventures with flamel
though flamel is referenced in the harry
potter books and films time and time
again
he never actually gets any screen time
in the original harry potter franchise
however flamel was featured and shown on
screen for the first time
in fantastic beasts the crimes of
grindelwald during gaelic grindelwald's
attempt as a tyrannical revolution
flamel reaches out to dumbledore and
offers up his home as a safe house
for any of their allies should they
require it flamel was supposedly a
kindly old man with a polite disposition
and this is clearly shown in the film
when he welcomes newt
jacob tina and yusuf into his home in
paris
during the events of fantastic beasts
flamel was already over 600 years old
but he still dedicated a considerable
amount of energy toward helping
dumbledore
newt and his other new allies with
defeating gaelic grindelwald
flamel in addition to being an
exceptionally gifted alchemist
the most famous of all time in fact was
also skilled in other areas of magic
his alchemical skill allowed him to
exercise his potion-making ability to
the greatest extent
eventually creating an elixir of life
that made the drinker immortal
flamel also had an extended knowledge of
the dark arts and a knowledge of
defensive magic that matched it
he even mastered divination being able
to use a crystal ball to see events
unfold
and was versed in both wondless and
non-verbal magic
though flamel could have lived forever
had he continued to utilize the
philosopher's stone
him and his wife eventually embraced
death flamel knew that the stone that he
had created
would ultimately bring more harm than
good if it fell into the wrong hands
and that's why he and dumbledore made
the decision to destroy it
flamel is such an interesting person
both inside and outside of the harry
potter universe
and i'm interested to see what his role
brings in the future fantastic beasts
films
we've got three more on the way so i'm
confident that we'll see more of flamel
what did you guys already know about
flamel i'm always wanting to continually
learn more about these interesting
historical figures that have made their
way into the harry potter universe
if i've missed something comment it down
below i'd love to hear what you guys
have to say
until next time you're a wizard hurry
you